bonjour merci de commencer cette semaine
sur tv 78 c'est l'heure du journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres de
ce lundi ils étaient 5000 collégiens
aujourd'hui au château de versailles est
venu des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
ils ont participé à une journée
citoyenne en partenariat avec la
fondation paris saint-germain children
first et thiago silva le joueur parisien
était présent elle l'est journée
nationale du don pour la croix rouge
c'est jusqu'au 26 mai des milliers de
bénévoles sur le terrain une action
indispensable à la poursuite de leurs
activités
nous en parlerons avec nos invités en
plateau et puis petit détour par à
cannes cette semaine nous irons chaque
soir rencontrer des yvelinois présent
pour le festival ce soir focus sur les
rendez-vous des exploitants de salles
le département les départements même des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
poursuivre leur collaboration ce lundi
au château de versailles cinq mille
collégiens des deux départements était
présent pour un programme qui se voulait
vivant ludique et créativement hélène ya
pishing habituellement fermé le lundi
les grilles du château de versailles ont
accueilli cinq minutes collégiens des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine pour une
journée spéciale une visite imaginé par
les deux présidents des départements qui
confirment leur forte collaboration
elle est très facile et très fluide et
nous espérons bien que d'ici la fin de
l'année nos deux départements n'en
feront plus qu'un seul
les élèves de classes de 4e bénéficié
d'une visite ponctuée par un orchestre
et d'ateliers sur l'écocitoyenneté la
chambre de luis saez l'agente de la
reine les salons un engagement commun
pour l'égalité des chances 84 collège
des deux départements ont pu participer
l'égalité des chances ça veut dire que
chaque enfant de nos départements
quel que soit son quartier quelle que
soit sa commune
quel que soit son milieu social doit
pouvoir accéder à la culture parce que
c'est la clé pour réussir ensuite où sa
vie professionnelle et où sa vie d'homme
je crois que c'est notre mission de
transmission qui se joue ici et le fait
que nous puissions dédié ce jour de
fermeture du château de versailles à
tous les scolaires est une magnifique
idée et qui a permis d'intensifier un
programme qui existait déjà
cerise sur le gâteau la visite du
capitaine de l'équipe de football du
paris saint germain
la fondation les enfants d'abord du club
et par haine de l'événement quand je
suis arrivée là les enfants ont commencé
à crier et tu vois
qui dans le visage et déjà quand ils ont
peut-être raison quand on me voit et
pour moi ça me touche beaucoup ça une
journée riche en souvenirs il est d'ores
et déjà prévu qu'elle soit reconduite en
2020 et 2021
jusqu'au 9 juin se déroule la semaine du
développement durable c'est à saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs communes
associées afin de proposer un programme
le plus complet possible entre
rencontres ateliers expositions et jeux
et ce week end un village climatique
itinérant a fait escale à voisins le
bretonneux l'occasion de présenter les
plans climats et paysages de
l'agglomération la vélostation lancé
voici un peu plus d'un an mais pas
seulement écouter ces quelques visiteurs
on met en avant justement les circuits
courts j'ai vu là j'ai vu que la laque
étaient sur place donc c'est super donc
voilà puis ça me permet aussi de montrer
à mon garçon back sur voisins ont fait
des choses
et justement ça serait bien qu'on en
fasse encore plus pour une ville
nouvelle je crois que c'est sympa quoi
bon c'est vrai qu'on est bien placé
pascal vallée de chevreuse il ya les
bois qui sont pas loin donc
ya pas mal de choses qui sont faites
pour l'environnement et le programme
complet des semaine du développement
durable est à retrouver sur le site de
saint quentin en yvelines je reçois à
présent deux invités bonjour à vous pour
denis largeteau vous êtes vice président
de la croix rouge et anaïs fayard vous
êtes la directrice locale urgence et
secourisme nous allons parler des
journées du don qui viennent de débuter
ce week end elles se poursuivent
jusqu'au jusqu'à la fin du jusqu'au 26
mai jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai elle
les bénévoles vont à votre rencontre
pour récolter des dons qui leur
permettent ensuite de poursuivre leur
action va tout de suite faire un premier
bilan de ce week end est ce que les
donateurs ont été généreux un peu moins
généreux que l'année dernière nous
sommes en recul de 1 peu plus de 18%
mais bon oui tout de même mais bon c'est
ça on a encore une semaine pour essayer
de rattraper notre notre retard et on
invite tous les gens à nous retrouver
sur les bords de la nationale 10 ou au
marché un mot repas ou à montigny quel
est l'accueil généralement du des gens
justement quand vous allez à leur
rencontre et ce qu'il cible bien on va
en parler ensuite mais ce qu'ils ciblent
déjà vos actions ah oui je pense que la
croix-rouge maintenant à une réputation
quand même qui n'est plus à faire tout
le monde nous connaît donc les gens les
gens viennent avec nous recevons un bon
accueil
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de souci
je vais donner quelques chiffres pour
vous vous rendiez compte de à quoi sert
votre argent justement un euro c'est
d'un repas 4 euros c'est un kit
d'hygiène 10 euros 30 couvertures de
survie pour un poste de secours 30 euros
consultations médicales 60 euros elle
c'est la formation de bénévoles pour la
prise en charge notamment des malades
d'alzheimer sont des actions très
diversifiés vous intervenez sur
l'urgence sur le secourisme serre
représentent quoi dans la part
d'activité déjà de la croix-rouge au
quotidien sur l'unité de saint quentin
en yvelines sur par rapport à je ne sais
pas j'ai aucune idée des chiffres que
notre
naïli excusez moi ça représente une
activité très importante un convoi pour
lui elle les secouristes sont présents
pratiquement tous les week-ends sur des
actions alors justement comment vous
intervenez où vous intervenez
concrètement alors en fait ils sortent
les organisateurs d'événements
maintenant l'obligation d'assurer des
secours dont ils se il ce retour il se
tourne vers nous pour pour qu'on assure
la sécurité de leurs postes il nous
donne toutes les informations du public
est attendu est ce que c'est une
manifestation sportive ou pas
le nombre de personnes suite à ça enfin
dimensionnement et on est on va sur le
post le jour j avec du matériel des
personnes formées des secouristes formés
et là notamment aux mois de mai juin on
est quasiment le sort tous les week-ends
et malheureusement on peut pas accéder
la plupart du temps aux demandes en
semaine parce que on est salarié par
ailleurs on voit pas rival du bénévolat
dans un instant on a un aperçu des ja du
travail que vous menez quels sont les
autres domaines dans les domaines
d'activité c'est d'abord en premier lieu
l'épicerie sociale où nous avons l'année
dernière fait l'équivalent de 300 mille
repas ce qui est quand même pour sept
duels importants et tu couvres saint
quentin en yvelines sont les douze
communes de l'agglomération donc c'est
assez important getafe et ensuite nous
avons des actions la vestiboutique qui
reçoit donc les gens qui ont besoin de
se vêtir
nous avons aussi une halte alzheimer
nous avons aussi une halte bébés par an
donc nous on nous multiplions les
actions qui permettent aux gens qui en
ont besoin de venir de se reposer que
pour l'alzheimer par exemple ou d'être
pris en charge par des gens pour les
et pour la h 2b b c'est important on a
besoin de bénévoles pour ouvrir encore
plus parce que malheureusement on peut
pas ouvrir la totalité de la semaine lui
elle c'est important à savoir lui elle
est ouvert 365 jours par an on ne ferme
jamais les bénévoles
il faut fonctionner l'alcoolisation
combien de bénévoles aujourd'hui sur
environ 160 160 donc ces journées sont
aussi du don sont aussi l'occasion pour
vous de sensibiliser au bénévolat
quel est le profil du bénévole
aujourd'hui c'est tout traître l arrière
c'est tout à fait ouverts c'est très
varié ça va de l'étudiant au retraité
puisque personnellement je suis retraité
mais c'est très varié on accepte tout le
monde toutes les bonnes volontés
les bénévoles qui interviennent sur les
différentes activités sur les vôtres en
l'occurrence ce sont aussi tous profils
ou s'il j'ai des personnes qui ont 16
ans jusqu'à je pense 70 ans on est on
fait du secourisme ce fut aussi la
formation aux gestes de premiers secours
donc il ya les deux profils au niveau
des métiers qui nous rejoignent à des
gens qui font
dans ses deux métiers qui sont
pharmaciens médecins il y en a d'autres
qui vont travailler dans les avions qui
vont travailler dans des centres aérés
les profils sont vraiment il n'ya pas de
crise du bénévolat si c'est
malheureusement les gens s'investissent
moins et sont plus justes disons que
pour l'instant on se rend compte que
c'est sporadiques
c'est à dire que la personne va va venir
voilà comme la consommation la personne
va venir une demi journée tous les mois
par exemple alors qu'on a besoin de plus
de personnes qui viennent plus souvent
d'abord parce que ben il faut remplacer
ceux qui peuvent pas être là totalement
les jours et puis donc on a besoin d'eux
par exemple à la halte bébé on ne peut
pas l'ouvrir toute la semaine alors
qu'il y aurait des demandes parce que
parallèlement il ya des demandes même si
côté de ça l'engagement des bénévoles
est moindre en tout cas il ya moins de
bénévoles pour pour s'en occuper
mais les demandes du public du grand
public elle reste important ce qu'il a
fait merci à tous les deux d'être venu
le site internet de la croix rouge cette
affiche et n'hésitez pas à donner vous
pouvez aussi aller à la rencontre des
bénévoles c'est même peu qui viendront à
voir se rencontrent pour récolter des
dons et puis sensibiliser au bénévolat
on l'a bien compris pour vous puissiez
donner aussi un peu de votre temps merci
à tous les deux d'être passé évoqué ces
journées et du don pour la croix rouge
en ce moment la solidarité toujours avec
le rôle des familles d'accueil et des
assistants familiaux les yvelines en
compte près de 600 un métier à plein
temps pour donner un cadre et attention
à des jeunes en difficulté des jeunes
mineurs parfois tout juste majeur mais
toujours en difficultés rencontrées
signé mélanie poquet ce pantalon c'est
le pantalon quand tu arrives et donc
vraiment tout petit et aujourd'hui ça ça
donne ça voilà à chaque fois qu'on le
regarde on est on rigole quand on est
mort de rire avec les enfants parce
qu'on se dit comment elle est arrivée
aujourd'hui à l'est elle est grande
comme ça les souvenirs à richard
conserve tout il y a cinq ans est
yvelinoise accueille une petite fille de
deux ans aujourd'hui encore présente
aucun du foyer c'était son premier
accueil comme assistante familiale dans
mon métier on n'est pas tout seul c'est
implique toute la famille
tout notre entourage aussi familiale
donc pour moi on est une famille
d'accueil
dans un contexte où ou les frères fatto
on a tous travaillé dans le milieu du
social et puis ma mère elle nous a
transmis ce ce dont deux femmes d'aller
vers les autres et ce don de soi
cette vocation elle la partage avec son
mari lui aussi assistant familial et l'a
transmise à sa fille elle samia 24 ans
actuellement en formation une formation
total de 300 heures la formation dure
deux ans on y ait deux jours par mois
donc c'est pas énorme ça nous permet de
nous organiser pour la garde des enfants
au cas où sont pas scolarisés ça permet
aussi de pouvoir dialoguer avec d'autres
collègues échanger des idées échangées
le notre quotidien en sept ans aicha et
sa famille ont accueilli près de 20
jeunes des enfants mais aussi des
adolescents comme léa aujourd'hui
majeurs la jeune fille n'hésite pas à
revenir dans cette famille qui l'a reçu
un temps à la base j'étais venu en
accueil d'urgence et j'étais venu pour
une soirée
au final je suis resté à presque un mois
donc c'était moi accueilli comme leur
famille comme si je faisais déjà partie
de la famille en fait donc c'est ça qui
a fait que je reste et je pense aussi
aïcha et samia travail pour le sda fille
le service d'accueil familial du
département les yvelines peuvent
accueillir jusqu'à 1400 jeunes dans le
besoin
les assistants familiaux s'occupe
d'enfants de la naissance à l'argenté un
an
on peut très bien avoir des parents
qu'ils nous disent j'en peux plus je ne
peux pas assurer la vie une vie correcte
à mes enfants donc en fait ils peuvent à
une remise une sorte de placement
volontaire par les parents la plupart du
temps ce sont des placements qui sont
les placements en fait fait sur une
décision du juge
selon les cas les parents conservent
leur autorité légale
aujourd'hui les yvelines contre est de
600 assistants familiaux
dernière ligne droite avant le scrutin
européen du dimanche 26 mai comme chaque
soir dans notre journal notre rendez
vous pour mieux connaître les
propositions des candidats aujourd'hui
william martin est président de l'unef
et candidat sur la liste de la france un
soubise le 26 mai toutes les françaises
et tous les français vont pouvoir avec
leurs bulletins de vote s'exprimer et je
pense que ce bulletin de vote il doit
servir à au moins deux choses d'abord
sanctionné
emmanuel macron c'est le premier scrutin
depuis les élections présidentielles de
nous avons un président qu'elle menait
une politique antisociale anti
écologique il faut être capable de le
sanctionner dans les urnes mais aussi
plus loin que ça le 26 mai c'est
l'occasion de réorienter la politique
européenne
nous avons besoin de coopération à
l'échelle de l'europe notamment pour
répondre à l'urgence climatique et c'est
ce que les députés de la france en somme
nous l avons fait c'est une politique
d'abord qui se donne les moyens de
sortir des traités dorothée les traités
européens
comme ils sont faits aujourd'hui ils
organisent la concurrence sociale et la
concurrence fiscale
c'est la course au dumping social et
fiscal est donc évidemment ça creuse les
inégalités ça dégrade les conditions de
vie de tout le monde il faut d'autres
règles du jeu au niveau européen est la
condition pour ça c'est de la mort de
sortir des traités il faut préserver nos
services publics notamment ceux de
transports et de l'énergie
si nous voulons faire une transition
écologique nous avons besoin d'organiser
un transport bas carbone ça veut dire
compter notamment sur le ferroviaire
alors même que en ce moment la
commission européenne et le président de
la république ouvre à la concurrence
privatise à tour de bras
et puis plus généralement une
proposition que nous faisons à la france
soumise à l'échelle européenne
elle se serait de mettre en place ce
qu'on appelle une règle
c'est plutôt que la règle absurde de
refuser des déficits publics
nous proposons une règle d'intérêt
général qui est de ne pas très prélevés
dans l'écosystème plus que ce qu'il a la
capacité de renouveler c'est ce qu'on
appelle la règle verte et c'est ce que
nous défendons qu à la france un soliste
et toutes nos séquences avec les
candidates et candidats à ce scrutin
européen en france sont à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile nous parlons économie à présent
avec des chefs d'entreprise portugais à
la rencontre du marché français un petit
déjeuner d'affaires elle s'est tenue à
versailles sur cette thématique objectif
mieux comprendre le fonctionnement à des
entreprises portugaises et nouer des
relations aurélie ronde et patrick
jacques de dixmude fait des affaires au
portugal
voici comment on pourrait résumer cette
matinée des changes à versailles
co-organisée par deux sociétés franco
portugaise de conseil en entreprise une
vingtaine d'entrepreneurs avaient
répondu présent il ya plus qu'un million
et sans que 5000 portugais qui sont qui
sont en france donc à la rédaction
c'est une réaction très bonne
d'affirmation de la communauté et notre
économie elle se développe tout cas avec
cette cette relation de confiance
depuis ces dernières années le portugal
bénéficie d'une des meilleures
croissances économiques de la zone euro
tourisme métallurgie ou encore commerce
extérieur les opportunités d'affaires y
sont nombreuses aussi bien pour les
entreprises versaillaise que portugaise
on a connu les gens très intéressants
des entrepreneurs qui veut travailler
avec nous qu'ils sont curieux qui vont
voir ce qu'on fait et ça porte ses
qualités de qualité européenne qu toutes
les certifications dans notre métier et
un prix très compétitif
il ya un chiffre qui m'a beaucoup
interpellé dans la présentation c'est
tout bêtement le chiffre du pib par tête
par habitant on ya 15000 euros au
portugal j'ai regardé combien on était
en france on a 35 milou fêtent le ratio
des deux vous avez compris et que le
goût du travail au portugal le rend le
pays extrêmement attractif notamment
pour les activités de services après
cette première édition positive pour les
organisateurs d'autres rencontre devrait
avoir lieu au cours de l'année
[Musique]
nous retrouverons comme chaque lundi
michaël et demi d'euros en plateau
bonjour michael bonsoir et on part le
sport il y avait du basket ce week end
playoffs c'est ça la basket américain
français c'est sa lente entre le
chesnay-versailles peut jubiler le fcb
78 réussi à éviter une revente à
d'assaut samedi 18 mai sur son temps en
quart de finale de prénationale
vainqueur 73 à 50 2 à l'aller face à
paris 14 les hommes de la cité royale se
sont imposés au retour 81 à 71 sur leur
parquet on écoute les réactions il
fallait être concentré respecté les
consignes et jouer au basket voilà tous
les matches qu'il faut gagner
donc même si on était à +21 on puisse
prendre donc d
c'était de gagner l'objectif c'était
véritablement de jouer pour gagner et
surtout pas de jouer pour ne pas perdre
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait du coup ça a
fait un match plein voilà ils se sont
défendus avec leurs armes et on a encore
été plus fort ce soir donc c'est
amplement mérité je pense
avec ce résultat l'entente le chesnay
versailles 78 de se qualifier pour le
final fort de la division l'équipe
affrontera meudon en demi-finale sur
terre un autre appareil pas d eau pour
une revanche dans deux semaines les me
donner les avait battus au mois de
février dernier en cas de victoire les
joueurs de la cité royale se verrait
propulsé en nationale 3 et après le
basket le football championnat de
régionale 3 trappe à peut-être laissé
passer sa chance pour remporter le titre
mais l'équipe a fait un grand pas vers
la montée les trappistes ont pu faire
mieux que match nul 1 but partout à 6
heures sur le terrain de rueil malmaison
un résultat qui leur permet d'être
deuxièmes à une journée de la fin du
championnat le strap conserve trois
points d'avancé sur son adversaire du
jour et un match nul le week-end
prochain pourrait leur offrir la montée
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon des
résultats du week end sur les yvelines
on vous retrouve dans quelques instants
pour le 7-8 sport et un point à beaucoup
plus complet sur l'actualité sportive du
sport à la culture plus de 3000
animations 2 millions de visiteurs le
week-end dernier 15e édition de la nuit
des musées manifestation européenne le
territoire yvelinois forcément répondu
présents à l'événement comme au musée de
la ville notamment où les objets de
notre quotidien ont rythmé la soirée
mélanie poker mêmes usages et les objets
ne se jette pas les exos l'ont bien
compris ils démontrent que la musique ce
n'est pas si compliqué c'est une vue de
l'esprit est un petit peu une image mais
il n'empêche que ça va ça montre que on
peut faire des choses avec des objets
qu'habituellement on balance on en
distribue un petit document qui
récapitule un petit peu ce qu'on a fait
qui donne les dimensions exactes des
tuyaux et le truc c'est vous pouvez
rentrer chez vous pouvez démonter toutes
les poutres inutile le musée de la ville
ouvrait plus longuement ses portes à
l'occasion de la nuit des musées une
soirée sous le signe des objets du
quotidien
465 personnes ont répondu présentes
le public de la nuit des musées c'est un
public et un petit peu différent c'est
sur une proposition en soirée donc plus
convivial au musée est un petit peu vu
différemment que on a deux voix toujours
de manière un peu austère quand il est
ouvert la journée là c'est l'occasion
aussi de montrer que c'est un lieu
ouvert à tous un succès confirmé dans
d'autres sites yvelinois au palais du
roi drôme de rambouillet près de 200
visiteurs ont enquêté sur les mystères
du site
[Musique]
pour cette première de la semaine
consacrée au festival de cannes nous
partons à la rencontre des exploitants
de salles locales ceux du grenier à sel
attrapé puis celui du ciné c'est aussi à
elancourt 6 km seulement partage par ta
part pardon sépare les deux cinémas
meygal pineau et lookbook en leurs
directeurs ont à coeur de venir ensemble
sur la croisette il y déniche de
nouveaux films ils échangent également
avec leurs pairs le reportage de grégory
canale et alexis garneau 12 ans qu'ils
viennent au festival de cannes leur
première c'était ensemble cette année
encore gaëlle pineau élue beaucamp sont
venus à deux pour une semaine de cinéma
un moment qui compte pour eux une bulle
d'oxygène dans leur quotidien
d'exploitants de salles
en tant que voisin on travaille
régulièrement ensemble on discute
beaucoup et de venir ici c'est on a les
mêmes informations en même temps on
prend du temps aussi ensemble on mange
ensemble régulièrement en dehors
ensemble pas dans le même lit mais dans
le même appartement
non mais c'est à un moment convivial
était aussi pour nous qui est vachement
important en vue d'années de travail
au programme de la semaine rencontres et
réunions avec les autres responsables
des cinémas art et essai beaucoup de
fils aussi pour assister à des
projections accessible grâce à une
accréditation et des invitations avec en
moyenne 1h30 d'attentes devant les
salles pendant toute l'année on regarde
pas autant le film que ça pourtant des
programmateurs donc beaucoup connaissent
un maximum donc là on fait le plein le
plein le plein de films pour ce 62e
festival luc et gaëlle ont vu une
vingtaine de films de la sélection
officielle à la semaine de la critique
trois ont particulièrement retenu leur
attention cette année on en parle on a
un peu les mêmes coups de coeur ah c'est
vrai qu'il ya papicha un film qui se
passe en algérie pendant les années 90
on a beaucoup aimé ce film là et c'est
sûr que attrape israël sera projeté il
ya aussi et aussi les misérables de la
sbee et puis aussi un très beau film
d'animation qui s'appelle j'ai perdu mon
corps qui à mon avis sera primé parce
que magnifique superbe film qu'on a vu
des coups de coeur que l'on devrait
retrouver dans les salles du ciné 7 et
du grenier à sel dans les prochains mois
et certains des films en compétition au
festival de cannes ou dans les
sélections parallèles ont été a financé
en partie par la région ile-de-france
accompagnement dans le cadre du fonds de
soutien au cinéma et à l'audiovisuel ou
encore ed
après réalisation le cinéma un secteur
porteur pour la région qui représente
plus de 150 mille emplois le point avec
grégory cannelle et depuis la croisette
l'ile-de-france bien présente pour ce
62e festival de cannes cette année seize
films soutenus par la région sont en
lice dans les différentes sélections aux
cannoises alors la région alloue un
budget de plus de 20 millions d'euros
cinéma et à l'audiovisuel c'est un
secteur porteur pour le territoire
ce chiffre en 2010 est 4200 cdi a créé
une progression de 15% par rapport à
l'année précédente
ces derniers chiffres ont été révélés
lors d'une conférence de presse à cannes
en présence de la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse
puis 250 mille emplois dans la filière
cinéma en ile de france ça veut dire que
et bien nous travaillons et grâce à ce
travail d'attractivité pour les films
nous créons des emplois mais dans tous
les domaines le décor les effets
spéciaux les techniciens du spectacle
nous on fonctionnait des studios parce
que nous sommes le hollywood français
faut quand même le dire nous avons la
moitié des studios français sont en ile
de france
donc le cinéma je ne suis pas là
uniquement pour parler culture je suis
là aussi pour parler emploi
développement d'une vraie filière
professionnelle en ile de france et
jusqu'à jeudi nous allons faire un focus
sur les films soutenus par la région ile
de france celui ci est en lice pour la
palme d'or les misérables est de l a dit
li la geely est en compétition dans la
sélection officielle du festival de
cannes le réalisateur de seine saint
denis le dit lui même et c'est un cri
d'alarmé des banlieues parisiennes une
plongée dans la réalité là des habitants
de montfermeil vu par un enfant
de l avis le policier à la brigade
anticriminalité on attend plus on
attendait le bus
[Musique]
68 ça c'est bon signe ça va je gère vos
films vous n'avez pas droit de faire ça
deux films et non des comptes en temps
c'est moi la loi donc en train de
m'expliquer koala c'est un accident
les psys nous lâche pas de piles talent
ces points de votre faute
comme d'hab quoi
s'il avait raison d'exprimer leur colère
seul moyen de se faire entendre
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition du journal
de la rédaction rendez vous demain 18h
pour un nouveau direct 19h pour la
première rediffusion dans un instant le
7-8 sport avec michael almy d'euros
excellente soirée
[Musique]